well bye oh don't be out too late now
we'll be back in a few days
you got your element same bro got you
answer the phone says if I call you I
will all right
so yeah you know there's been a lot
going on in the house yes there has been
a lot of conversations drama yeah yeah
and I you know I didn't really want to
go our first date that I've asked you on
I didn't really want to go over the top
I thought about taking her somewhere
fancy you know a nice restaurant things
like that but she's been clear from day
one that she's more of a homebody I want
her to know that I hear her and that I
want the life she wants I just want to
really take a moment and tell you how I
feel if you're with the right person I
believe that it doesn't matter if you
had a five-star Resort or in your own
backyard it just really matters the time
you put into each other last bouquet
that I made I screwed it up right I
thought it looked nice this is two dozen
white lilies you can take a look at it
so you know the white lilies represent
New Beginning
I'm just gonna say New Beginning so have
a seat I want to talk to you oh man I
noticed something the first time I saw
you down your back you have butterflies
right yes so what I want you to do I
want you to open this
okay
oh no way two dozen butterflies when a
butterfly is born it's in a cocoon right
it's in a real dark place sometimes and
it becomes something beautiful and
that's what I see you as
I'm all in I'm serious about you
um
my best friend in high school
she passed away so the first butterfly
that I got
was for her
um because I've always connected
butterflies to her so that's why I love
butterflies so much so this means
I feel a lot more than me I didn't want
to do anything over the top just
something that's meaningful from me to
you let you know I see you in your whole
process you're making it really hard for
everyone else